so to start here if you guys had the
opportunity to swap roles with anyone in
the Star Wars film franchise who would
you pick and why I mean kylo Ren rolls
pretty it's pretty good snazzy in a
popular answer today what would about
could the darkness because you can just
like nah you know just unleash all of
that yeah age and you know the helmet
stresses me out it just doesn't look
comfortable to be in that most of the
day but it's it's really fun actually
there's like it's like helmets are
awesome is it that all comfortable for
you no okay you just like that it's just
this incredible power play because you
when you're dressed in well at least my
outfit it's so tough on the exterior and
has this whole vibe to it and all these
this gear and he's like and then the
helmet you feel so invincible and people
look at you so I would walk on set and
all the crew dudes would be like yeah
yeah what's out anything what's up I
never I always want to feel like that
but I never do is this the kind of role
or if you've ever fantasized about being
in a Star Wars movie is zouri kind of
what you pictured for yourself it's
ideal like it's it's not some girl like
in distress she's totally capable
threatening mysterious she's everything
it's like everything I could possibly
want to do although there's some stuff
that Daisy does physically in this
mm-hmm that I was bonkers I was watching
this going yeah [ __ ] yeah I like I loved
it I can't wait for all my kids to see
it but especially my daughter I was just
like ah I love like that first big thing
in the desert one did so pumped I have
to ask you guys about a little someone
called baby Yoda right now hottest thing
melting hearts all over the place so
we're gonna play
game right now so if you had a fill in
the bunk
baby baby Otis first what that you would
want to see what would it be so baby
Yoda's first words first Christmas
something like that what would you want
to see and how would it happened you say
baby Yoda's first poop if that's what
you want you gotta poop does yoda have
saying that's disturbing when you frog
sorry babies there's equal poop to me
right now yeah that's uh it's not not a
false statement yeah this is really
interesting
baby Otis first I'm to see the does Yoda
levitate Yoda levitates I think they all
can live it ya know
right I would watch that yeah if you
guys had the opportunity to continue
your character stories on a Disney Plus
series would you take it
nope cashing in my chips he's done his
time in the universe in the galaxies